Das Buch Angst Stillstand von Richard David Precht ist in aller Munde. Und wir haben uns entschieden, die ersten 15 Minuten aus dem ausführlichen Salongespräch zu veröffentlichen. Den gesamten Salon gibt es bei Steady, Apple oder Patreon zu abonnieren. Wir, also Stefan und ich, reden dann zwei Stunden über dieses thesenstarke Buch von Richard David Precht, dem wir mitunter zustimmen, dem wir aber auch vehement widersprechen müssen.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie viel Angst hast du?
Ich habe nicht so viel Angst, weil ich gar nicht so leicht sanktioniert werden kann.
Okay, es sind keine Sanktionsmöglichkeiten. Das ist ja schon mal hochinteressant.
Ja, darum geht es ja bei dieser Angst, die Herr David Precht beschreibt. Also was damit gemeint ist, ist, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise bei einem Fernsehsender wäre oder bei einer Produktionsgesellschaft, dann könnte es ja passieren, dass man sagt, also hör mal diese Aussage da, die du da in deinem Podcast getroffen hast, mach das nicht nochmal. Sonst wissen wir nicht, wir wollten dir eigentlich eine neue Sendung geben, aber sieht schwierig aus. Da ich aber ja bei mir selbst quasi angestellt bin, kann mir das ja nicht passieren. Insofern kann man in Shitstorms geraten oder bekommt Kritik, aber es ist nicht diese Art der Sanktionierung möglich, wie das vielleicht bei anderen der Fall ist. Und deswegen kann ich ein bisschen freier von Angst mich da bewegen, wenngleich eine völlige Angstfreiheit natürlich nie existieren kann.
Typischerweise fangen wir mit den archimetischen Punkten von diesen Büchern an, um sie zu besprechen. Jetzt sind wir direkt bei der Achilles Ferse. Denn Richard David Brecht ist genau diese Unterscheidung wahnsinnig wichtig. Es geht darum, Sanktionsmöglichkeiten aufzuzeigen, wie zum Beispiel wir entziehen dir Budget, wir entziehen dir Leute, wir entziehen dir deine Sendelizenz, was auch immer wir jetzt so gesehen haben. Offenbar strecken Funktionäre davor zurück. So, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Dieses Buch beginnt aber ganz woanders. Nämlich seit über 70 Jahren stellt das Institut für Demoskopie Allensbach, den Menschen in Deutschland, jedes Jahr die Frage, kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern oder sollte man besser vorsichtig sein? Und dieses Ergebnis ist über Jahrzehnte relativ konstant, hat Höhenwerte bis 83 Prozent. Dann allerdings beginnt eine Talfahrt in den 2000ern, es kommt zur Corona-Pandemie und so weiter und so fort und zack 45 Prozent. 2023 gerade einmal 40 Prozent sagen, sie glauben, sie können hier ihre Meinung frei äußern und müssten nicht vorsichtig sein. Hier redet man also über eine gesamte Bevölkerung, die genau diese Funktionärs-Sanktionsmöglichkeiten eigentlich gar nicht, denen das gar nicht droht. Weil denen wird weder eine Sendelizenz weggenommen, noch wird ein Budget entzogen.
Die gehen morgen in den Handwerksbetrieb und alles ist wie immer.
So. Und diesen Zwiespalt löst dieses Buch nicht auf, finde ich. Also man kann es ja auch mal jetzt, wo wir schon so angefangen haben, dramatisch beginnen und sagen, das Buch weist auf ein paar interessante Phänomene und Probleme hin, aber es macht auch ganz schön große auf, über die ich bisher noch nicht nachdachte und die aber hier auch nicht aufgelöst werden.
Ich finde schon, dass es aufgelöst wird, nämlich es wäre erstmal leicht zu sagen, das ist ein Buch, in dem sich Richard David Precht mit seiner Rolle als öffentlicher Intellektueller auseinandersetzt, der dann möglicherweise sanktioniert wird, nicht mehr im Föjeton besprochen wird oder sonst etwas. Und ja, das trifft natürlich da alles zu, aber dann würde ich sagen, das ist das Problem von einem Prozent der Menschen, nämlich die, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, irgendetwas sagen oder so. Wenn aber jetzt Menschen befragt werden, habt ihr den Eindruck, dass die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet und sie antworten in so großer Zahl mit Ja. Dann bedeutet das tatsächlich, glaube ich nicht, dass sie das insofern antworten, als sie Angst haben, morgen etwas ihrem Nachbarn zu erzählen, morgen bei der Familienfeier schweigen zu müssen oder im Betrieb die ganze Zeit den Mund halten zu müssen. Sowieso muss man ja auch hier nochmal fragen, was meinen wir hier mit Meinung? Das wird ja nicht aufgeschlüsselt, denn man kann ja generell sagen, wo die Werkstore durchschritten werden, hört die Meinungsfreiheit sowieso auf. Man kann durchaus sich politisch äußern in der Mittagspause zu Kollegen oder vielleicht auch während der Arbeit, aber es gibt eben ganz viele Dinge, die wird man während der Arbeitszeit nicht sagen können, zum Beispiel über die Gedanken, die man so hat über den Vorgesetzten, welche Kritik man eigentlich äußern würde und sie nicht äußern kann. Deswegen haben wir Betriebsräte, Opläute, dafür gibt es Gewerkschaften. Wir sehen also, da gibt es ja ein generelles Machtverhältnis, mit dem sich Richard David Precht gar nicht auseinandersetzt. Das wäre auch mal zu fragen, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit der Meinungsfreiheit? Ich hatte mal hier im Salon dieses Interview gebracht von Katharina Pistor, die in den USA ja lehrt und gefragt wurde, wie kann das denn sein, fragte das Handelsband, dass die Leute jetzt nicht rebellieren gegen Trump und seine Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit an Universitäten. Und sie sagte ja da, die meisten Leute leben ja acht Stunden am Tag in Diktaturen, wo sie ihre Meinung nicht frei äußern können, nämlich in Unternehmen. Und jetzt ist für die es eher so, dass sie sagen, das geschieht den Professoren mal ganz recht, dass die jetzt auch mal erleben, wie es ist. Ja, das fand ich eine sehr, sehr interessante Überlegung von Katharina Pistor. Wird das aber jetzt aufgelöst, weil man jetzt sagen kann, dann sind es ja zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe zunächst mal, dass man sagt, da sind Leute in der Öffentlichkeit, die werden sanktioniert, aber die normalen Leute können ja einfach so weiter reden. Ich glaube, es löst sich in der Weise auf, dass die Leute also diese Frage beantworten mit, ja, die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet, indem sie an die denken, die öffentlich sanktioniert werden. Sie wissen, dass sie nicht dazugehören. Sie sind nicht der Comedian, nicht der Rockstar oder sonst wer, der nicht mehr dann stattfindet. Aber sie identifizieren sich in gewisser Weise schon mit ihm. Sie sehen eine Art Stellvertreter darin und hinzukommt, dass es ja darum geht, welche vorherrschende Moral oder welche vorherrschende Meinung, welche Hegemonie erleben wir, wenn wir zum Beispiel Nachrichten schauen. Und wenn wir dort fortwährend hören, dass eigentlich alle Waffenlieferungen wollen, jeder Journalist, ob von Taz bis Welt, alle sagen im Prinzip Ähnliches, dann stellt sich also schon bei den Rezipienten, die das anders sehen, wo immer 40 Prozent sagten, naja bitte nicht Waffen liefern, nicht so viele zumindest und all das, stellt sich also die Frage, was stimmt hier nicht? Darf man das offenbar nicht mehr sagen. Das heißt, sie dürfen das ihren Nachbarn sagen, sie können das auch abends in der Kneipe sagen, ich finde verrückt, wie der aufgerüstet wird. Aber sie wissen, also im allgemein anerkannten Diskurs ist das nicht mehr das, was gesagt werden darf. Und diese Sache ist natürlich nicht ganz deckungsgleich, aber ich finde, dass sich das dadurch etwas auflöst, dieser Widerspruch, der von dir beschrieben wurde.
Ja, bis zu deinem Satz eben, das ist nicht ganz deckungsgleich, fand ich das sehr plausibel, was du gesagt hast. Und ich will es auch noch mal reformulieren, in einer Demoskopie, die wir kennen. Und da überprüfen wir mal, ob das nicht einfach gar nicht deckungsgleich ist. Denn diese Allensbach-Umfrage wird ja auch zum Thema, wie geht es Deutschland wirtschaftlich und wie ist deine eigene Lage wirtschaftlich gemacht? Die Leute sagen, Deutschland geht es ganz schlecht. Ich bin ganz pessimistisch, was die Zukunftsaussicht unserer Schicksalsgemeinschaft angeht. Auf die Frage hin, wie geht es dir persönlich? Super. Also wirklich 80-20. Bei der Frage, kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern? Ich würde sagen, wir haben mittlerweile das Phänomen, dass Leute sagen, klar, ich habe noch nie bei einer Insta-Story drüber nachgedacht, was ich da sage, aber dass der Jimmy Kimmel in Amerika gecancelt wird, halte ich für ein ernsthaftes Problem. Also ja, man kann seine Meinung nicht mehr frei äußern. Also wir müssen bei dieser Fragestellung, die steht auf ganz schwammigem Grund, wenn sie einfach lautet, kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern. Und dann schlägt das Buch aber um und er hat ja den Richard Thaunmüller als ganz großen Anwalt seiner Sache, der eben dieses Bild der subjektiven Meinungsfreiheit formuliert. Also subjektiver nimmt ja schon mal den objektiven Charakter aus, das handelt er auch schnell ab. Laut Grundgesetz findet keine Zensur statt, aber die subjektive Meinungsfreiheit ist trotzdem. Diese Zahlen sind ja erschreckend. 58 Prozent oder was auch immer sagen Nein darf man nicht. In Deutschland gibt es keine Meinungsfreiheit mehr. Und auf diesen doppelschwammelten Grund, also der Undifferenziertheit, ob man sich selber meint oder Phänomene beobachtet, die einen Sorge bringen zur Meinungsfreiheit, aus denen leitet er dann eine persönliche Angst als maßgeblich für das Problem, das er im Folge dessen dann aufschlüsseln möchte. Leitet eine persönliche Angst ab. Die Leute haben Angst. Und das kriege ich nicht ganz zusammen. Also diese Angst sehe ich nicht. Deswegen auch meine Eingangs-Joke-Frage an dich. Handelt dieses Buch davon, dass alle Angst haben oder dass alle infantil einfach nur noch ins Internet, ohne nachzudenken, was sie eigentlich sagen, Vollmühlen.
Und er beschreibt ja beide Phänomene. Das ist ja das Interessante. Er beschreibt ja genau die Leute, die zu allem eine Meinung haben und loslegen und alles ins Internet schreiben, was ihnen so gerade durch den Kopf rauscht.
Also haben sie jetzt Angst oder eben gerade nicht?
Und das ist interessant, dass wir, glaube ich, hier diese Idee der Identifikation haben. Das arbeitet er nicht so heraus. Das müsste man aber eigentlich tun. Dass man zwar für sich sagen kann, ich kann hier alles machen, ich schreibe hier nochmal was rein, was nicht opportun ist. Und damit will ich sagen, nicht opportun, das kann im positiven Sinne nicht opportun sein oder im von mir bewährdet negativen Sinne nicht opportun sein. Aber die Leute, die in irgendeiner Position sind, wo es auf was ankommt, zum Beispiel Journalisten und Talkshow-Moderatoren oder so, da ist das schon wieder anders. Die müssen sich in einer anderen Weise rechtfertigen. Also identifiziere ich mich mit denen. Wie geht das Ding gerade? Nun, dass wir uns so mit diesen Figuren, die wir irgendwo sehen, identifizieren, das ist ja ganz logisch, dass das passiert. Die Frage ist, wie überträgt man es auf sich selbst? Ich glaube auch, dass solche Umfragen in gewisser Weise sich selbst bestätigen. Irgendwann Leute hören, die meisten Leute sagen, man kann ja nicht mehr frei seine Meinung äußern. Wenn sie das nächste Mal gefragt werden, darf man auch frei seine Meinung äußern? Sagen sie, nee, ich habe ja auch schon mal gehört, das darf man nicht mal. Also nein, man darf nicht mehr frei seine Meinung äußern. Das ist sicherlich als als so ein Gefühl und sich selbst verstärken, das Element zu nennen. Was ich aber glaube, was wichtig ist und was Richard David Precht auch tut, ist zu zeigen, dass es diese subjektive Meinungsfreiheit gibt. Er sagt, Freiheitsentzug droht nur bei schweren Beleidigungen, der klaren Verletzung von Persönlichkeitsrechten, öffentlichen Aufrufen zu Gewalt oder der öffentlichen Deugnung der deutschen Verbrechen bei der Shoah. Das ist so, und da hat sich wenig dran.
Bis er das am Ende selber aufbricht und sagt, wenn Nancy Feser so ein Gesetz macht oder man wegen Schwachkopf schon in der Heustastudium, das ist ja auch nicht nur eine subjektive, sondern eine sehr objektive.
Da geht es dann, er beschreibt dann neue Phänomene der letzten Jahre, nicht nur Phänomene, sondern Versuche der Gesetzesänderung oder tatsächliche Gesetzesänderung. Auf die kommen wir dann gleich noch. Aber bei Richard Traunmüller bezieht er sich auf die subjektive Meinungsfreiheit und da heißt es, die Kosten der freien Meinungsäußerungen. Und das ist wichtig. Beginne nicht erst dort, wo eine verlautbare Meinung justiziabel ist. Man muss auch fragen, wann ist es günstig, sich zu äußern? Das ist dann der Fall, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Äußerungen sanktioniert werden, gering ist und die Sanktionen selbst geringe Kosten mit sich bringen. Bedeutet also, je geringer die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, für seine Meinung in irgendeiner Form sanktioniert zu werden, umso größer ist die Meinungsfreiheit. Jetzt sagt er in einem Klima, aber der Angst, was immer das dann genau meinen mag, müssen wir mal gucken, sind also Leute nicht mehr bereit, ihre Meinung zu sagen, weil sie sagen, sonst drohen mir Sanktionen. Bedeutet also nicht, dass man sagt, da hat es aber ordentlich gekracht in der Talkshow, da waren verschiedene, unterschiedliche Positionen, sondern wir sehen dann entsprechend bei Twitter-Reaktionen, geht gar nicht, den dürft ihr nie wieder einladen, solche Leute sind abschauen, was auch immer. Jetzt kann man immer sagen, da sind wir in dem Bereich der Talkshow, des Medienzirkus, aber das überträgt sich ja immer auch auf die Normalbevölkerung, dass sie also oft nur eine eingebildete Angst hat, weil sie in der Regel sich auch gar nicht ständig im Supermarkt oder sonst wo politisch äußert, wo man dann gemaßregelt werden könnte. Aber es ist nun so, dass der Zuschauer, der Publikum ist, sich zugleich aber auch identifiziert mit denen, die dort in den Talkshows sitzen, mit den Protagonisten. Und ich glaube, dass damit schon sehr viel gesagt werden kann. Und damit ist auch beschrieben, warum dann so eine sehr konforme Meinung zu vielen wichtigen Themen entsteht. Also dass beispielsweise aus meinem Umfeld mir Leute sagen, die angewiesen sind auf irgendwelche Fördergelder oder die in größeren Strukturen sind. Ich kann mich nicht zum Thema Nahost äußern. Ich kann mich nicht zum Thema Wehrpflicht äußern. Das bedeutet also, diese Angst ist da. Und wenn dann jetzt wieder Leute sagen werden, wie damals schon bei dem Buch mit Harald Wälzer, ja, aber Precht, wovon redet er denn? Der ist doch erfolgreich. Ja, der muss keine Angst haben, denn der kann nicht mehr sanktioniert werden. Man kann dem jetzt die ZDF-Sendung wegnehmen. Meine Güte, er wird genug Geld verdient haben und sagt das ja auch so in Interviews. Wir müssen uns keine Sorgen um ihn machen.
Genau, also diese Umstände usw., alle eingepreist, das ist sehr wichtig. Precht hat das bei Jung und Naiv auch nochmal betont gestern. Auf die Frage hin, die saloppe Frage von Thilo, willst du nicht zu Gaza was sagen oder so? Sagt dann Precht einfach, nein, mir wurde schon mal das Antisemitismus-Label angehangen. Das war nicht schön, das würde ich nie wieder erleben. Zu diesem Thema sage ich eher weniger. Also ganz explizit Umgang mit einer Angst, wie er sie ja im Buch verorten möchte. Ich will trotzdem nochmal sagen, dass diese Angst hier auf sehr schwammigem Grund steht, und zwar unnötigerweise. Ich bin selber ein großer Fan des Alarmismus. Ich bin in die Frank-Schönmacher-Schule gegangen. Ein Thema aufzugreifen, bei dem die Welt nicht untergeht, lohnt fast nicht. Deswegen Demografie, Familie und so weiter. Nun haben wir es hier, finde ich, trotzdem mit einem überspitzen Alarmismus zu tun. Denn diese Angst, von der er ausdrücklich sagt, diese Angst ist nicht präzise real messbar, sondern eben nur gefühlt, bindet er zurück an die Meinungsfreiheit, von der ich schon sage, es ist jetzt so ein bisschen, ich will hier schon mal die Aufklärung, geht es jemanden um die eigene persönliche gefühlte Meinungsfreiheit oder das Gefühl, wie es in der Gesellschaft um die Meinungsfreiheit bestellt ist oder um konkrete andere, die gerade gekanzelt werden, denen man Solidarität ausspricht. So, und für ihn ist aber, wenn ich sage, von der Angst zur Meinungsfreiheit ist der Brückenschlag schon ein bisschen wackelig. Macht er einen Brückenschlag von der Meinungsfreiheit zur Demokratie, den wir alle sympathisch finden, aber der auch sehr wackelig ist? Denn bei ihm ist ja Demokratie ist gleich Meinungsfreiheit, sagt er ja ausdrücklich. Steht ja wirklich mit dem Ist, mit dem Gleichheitszeichen so ein Satz. Und das finde ich...
Da würdest du widersprechen?
Ja, ich will da nicht widersprechen. Ich kann da voll mit sympathisieren und sage, ja klar, ohne Meinungsfreiheit. Wohin führt uns denn die Demokratie, wenn wir denen das Vorfeld einer politischen Wahl nicht ordentlich spielen können? Ja, also wenn da keine Freiheit herrscht. Nur, ich würde gerne, also ich würde sehr gerne über diese Angst, über den Hegemon, über den Cursor des gefühlten Anstands und so weiter ganz viel reden. Hab ich auch schon. Ich habe den Herrn Hegemon, wer ist das eigentlich? Wer verpflichtet hier wen zu welcher Rechtfertigung und so weiter, damit es im Diskurs weitergeht? Ich möchte damit gerne, also ich möchte gerne über diese Themen reden, ohne dass die vorher zubetoniert werden. Mit so einer Tragfähigkeit, wo ich denke, nee, da muss jetzt gar kein Atombonker drum gebaut werden mit Demokratie ist Meinungsfreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit in Gefahr durch Angst. Also jedes Mal, wenn wir jetzt über Angst- und Rechtfertigungspflichten stehen, ist immer gleich die Demokratie in Gefahr. Ich finde, die Demokratie ist wegen sehr vielen in Gefahr, vor allem auch wegen Meinungsfreiheit und wie man mit ihr umgeht. Wir haben ja die Fälle in Amerika, also die Universitäten werden weggecancelt, beim Fernsehen wird krass eingegriffen. Das läuft alles über diese Geoökonomie eigentlich, dass man nämlich da sagt, ja die Eigentumsrechte sind halt jetzt so und so und wir haben die FTC und wer auch immer oder die FTC, dass man da einfach Zugriff hat. Nur, ich würde gerne über dieses Hegemann- und Cursor-Phänomen reden, ohne dass gleich der Antichrist mit im Raum steht.
Ich bin nicht sehr dafür und das ist wirklich ein...
Weil manchmal sind es wirklich einfach nur Gefühlslagen so, ja?
Ich möchte fast sagen, es ist eine Krankheit der heutigen Sachbücher, dass egal wo... Dies ist erst der Beginn eines intensiven zweistündigen Gesprächs über Angststillstand von Richard David Precht. Wir fragen uns noch weiter, warum ist die Klassenfrage eigentlich so unterbelichtet in dem Werk? Weshalb sind einige Beispiele, die aus der Kulturbranche herangezogen werden, vielleicht eher unbeholfen? Und was müsste man außerdem noch zur Meinungsfreiheit sagen? Und inwiefern ist sie noch bedroht? Was ist es, was vielleicht im Buch zu kurz kommt? Wir diskutieren angeregt weiter. Das alles kann man hören, wenn man den Salon der Neuen Zwanziger abonniert. Das ist möglich über Apple, Patreon und das empfehlen wir besonders über Steady. Vielen Dank.